[Music]
do any books come to mind or people
who you find or that you find
particularly interesting
or informative with respect to
geopolitical strategy
brinksmanship on this geopolitical
three-dimensional chess board or warfare
in any capacity for people who would
like to get a better understanding of
how these games are played maybe
historical precedence how different
conflicts
have turned out depending on different
stratagems used by opposing parties for
instance
any books or people
you find
interesting
yeah so one is something that a lot of
listeners will have heard of maybe all
listeners will have heard of and some
will have read especially people who are
veterans and definitely people who've
been in the service academies will have
read
and it's not that long and it's
unbelievably good and it's this book
called on war
by von klausewitz a german general
it's the single most influential book on
war written since
sun tzu's art of war
and as i said it's required reading in
military academies in every country in
the world
it's shockingly well written
it's unbelievably clear
and
it has a very specific philosophical
view about what war is like and what war
is for
and it's famous for the line that war is
the continuation of politics by other
means
and
that's a profound statement
because it suggests that war
serves the interests of political actors
and is prosecuted to achieve those
interests
but the other thing about it that's
really fascinating is he wrote it from
the point of view that says the only
smart way to fight a war is to fight it
absolutely
without holding back
put all your chips on the table
and try to win the war
and
that maximizes the odds that you will
and it'll be over faster and if it's
over faster that's also good for
everybody he says because then it won't
kill more people and eat up more
resources
and yet despite the fact that the first
idea of fun class of it's the idea that
wars politics by other means is accepted
by everybody in the domain of war and
politics
there are lots of wars that aren't
fought in the extreme all-out fun class
of its wet tons of them including a
bunch of u.s wars which have not been
fought that way wars which notably we
haven't won
you know courts like vietnam and iraq
and arguably even afghanistan
so i would strongly recommend that book
i can't actually recommend it strongly
enough
it really makes you think
and they're you know it's easy to buy
you can buy it in any bookshop and i'm
sure you could buy it on amazon you know
in 20 seconds
in terms of contemporary people
writing about the geopolitics
you know i really like to mix and match
i
like to read work by
people who are thought of as realists
who think that national self-interest is
all that matters and i like to read work
by people who are called idealists who
think that moral principles matter as
well and i really like historical
perspective so on anything to do with
ukraine
i love the work of a historian called
tim snyder who teaches at yale
and
he's
first of all a fantastic historian who's
genuinely a ukraine expert i mean his
first few books before he got famous
were highly technical historical studies
of ukrainian history
and then each book he writes gets a
little broader in terms of its audience
and now he writes very broad in general
books
and he's a terrific historian and he's
really the person to read on ukraine and
its history
and he also takes you beyond just
ukraine
and discusses the relationship between
germany and russia
and
really the whole 20th century's concept
of war
which interestingly he thinks of ukraine
as having been at the middle of not
because ukraine was so important but
because the countries germany and russia
that were fighting these wars were
fighting in part over the territory that
includes ukraine so i would strongly
recommend any of his books his grand
book is called bloodlands
it's
long
and
intense but it's very very very
beautifully and and clearly written and
if you can you know if you can stomach a
book about the wars of the 20th century
you'll learn a ton about geopolitics and
the region in the process
thank you for those recommendations
sounds like i have some fun classifieds
to read
first and foremost you're going to love
one class of bits
you're going to like saying the name he
would totally be on your podcast if you
were still alive
you